♪♪
Lin:
I was a wanted man on the run
with no home in that first Bombay minute.
Lin:
Hope and cheer felt much the
same.
♪♪
Shantaram is a book that
believes in the human spirit
Steve Lightfoot:
and so I was very excited when
the chance to adapt it came up.
Charlie Hunnam:
I love this novel.
I was blown away by the scope.
By reading this book it made me
feel seen,
it made me feel my
experiences in India mattered
and were relevant.
♪♪
Steve Lightfoot:
Shantaram is a first-person
novel
being changed into a very
different storytelling form.
♪♪
They were going to do it as a
film but there is just no way
you can do justice
Charlie Hunnam:
to this material in two and a
half hours.
It needs the breadth and scale
and scope of a series.
Lin:
I think freedom's all you can
ask for.
In the end, choice is all we
have.
Charlie Hunnam:
Bombay nineteen eighty-one.
The attention to detail and the
work that’s
Charlie Hunnam:
been put into creating these
sets.
Just the beauty of them. I mean
just [CHEF’S KISS].
Bharat Nalluri:
It’s an extraordinary feat to
pull off
but the real genius at the heart
of the series
Bharat Nalluri:
is to find complex characters we
really care about.
Antonia Desplat:
All the characters are
multidimensional.
We really are diving in to see
all the worlds
of those different people within
the same city.
I felt the character "Lin" in my
heart and my soul.
I can’t get involved in whatever
it is you guys do.
All the characters,
Bharat Nalluri:
they’re all strangers in a
strange land
Bharat Nalluri:
and they all have
their secrets and lies.
♪♪
They’re all drawn to Indian
warmth and beauty of that
culture,
(All)
Hey!
but it’s also a dangerous place
and a dark place.
Only a fool plays a game without
knowing the rules first.
♪♪
Ultimately, that line between
good and evil
is the tightrope that the story
is walking.
♪♪
Lin:
Here, maybe I get a second
chance.
Lin:
A reckoning with my fate.
♪♪